a lot of men aren't taken seriously when
they're when they're when they thought
you were walking down the street and you
see some dodgy Geezer walking towards
you and you think he's gonna hurt me and
you think oh across the road I'll call
my mate I'll do this I'll do that and
then you do that let me carry on So You
Think oh I will leave him because that
Dodge Giza is gonna hurt me so I will
cross the road I'll go home I'll call my
mate and off and you do that the chances
are I will just go on a [__] course
I'll go work with someone I'll just fall
asleep in front of them and they will
because the chances are they will okay
okay
but here's the right here I'm not either
here's the oh here I might fall asleep
in front of you and all three yeah it's
all good games anyone's [__] wants me
it's a [__] joke don't say it's not
all men because it is